[Music]
the times 20 kaio-ken on nabek I think
it's fair to say that this is a scene
that epitomizes everything that
Dragonball is seen to be about
admittedly I've gone back and forth on
the matter but time and time again I
found myself coming to call this scene
my absolute favorite from the series I'm
sure I'm not the only one from the
shocking realization that Goku is using
the kaio-ken all ready to go coos battle
cry to the breathtaking Kamehameha it's
easy to see why this scene is remembered
as fondly as it is but this iconic scene
has had many different iterations over
the last 25 years and believe it or not
there are some key differences between
them and today I will be focusing and
reviewing four of them going in order of
release
I will first take a look at the original
manga chapter from 1991 the original
Japanese broadcast from the same year
followed by the Funimation edit and
dubbed from 1999 katha Ganahl off with
Dragon Ball Z Kai's read dubbed version
from the year 2010 to round out our four
options but the interesting thing about
this video is that I won't be the one
deciding which one is best at the end
you will once each of these versions has
been reviewed and broken down I will at
the end of this video offer you the
viewer a chance to vote in a poll for
your favorite telling of this epic scene
with that out of the way let's begin
with the very first time we see this
legendary scene hit the public eye and
to do that we have to go all the way
back to February 19 1991 titles Kyle
Kane times 20 this was written and drawn
entirely by Akira Toriyama in the early
90s distributed to the public via Weekly
Shonen Jump the cover art for this
chapter sees an exhausted Goku at his
limit with his hands up ready to
continue fighting as a smug Frieza
and concerned King Kai look on this
particular chapter is exactly 14 pages
long beginning right after King Kai
reveals that Goku had in fact been using
the kaio-ken times 10 to no effect
against Frieza which is the last panel
of the previous chapter and that's one
major cliffhanger but enough of the
previous chapter how does this chapter
tell the events
well it begins as you might expect with
Frieza absolutely brutalizing goku and
traicee might cannot come close to
matching Frieza in this face-off who
while clarion greeting at Goku casually
slices a hole in the planet's surface
leaving a shocked Goku to remark from
boy I can't win the artwork during this
section of the story is a transitional
period for a curatorial he's not quite
the hyper angular artist he would
eventually become in the Buu saga but
he's certainly not retaining the round
soft approach from earlier Dragon Ball
line that aside this era of Toriyama
provided some of my favorite
illustrations for the entire series the
scene continues as Frieza flies up and
lands in front of Goku reassuring him he
won't kill him just like that slash he
made to the planet that would be
terribly unsatisfying meanwhile the guys
and all the world are panicking King Kai
warned him not to tangle with Frieza
King Kai remarks
he's lost but Goku has an idea I could
try a kaio-ken increase to 20 times on
one hand there's the very real
possibility that Goku's body can take
the sun's surge of power and on the
other if Frieza wasn't bluffing and is
only using half of his true power then
it's useless anyway but Goku assumes
that he is bluffing
using his trump card the kaio-ken in
ways he never thought he'd have to he
begins to power up as a massive Horace -
to envelop his body staring daggers
through Frieza he thinks to himself
please let him be bluffing this time
Goku explodes off the mark with a
massive punch connecting with Frieza
catching the tyrant off-guard
Goku chases after chanting kha they he
attempts to punch again but this time
Frieza evades ha they Goku locks eyes
with Frieza and releases at that moment
the most powerful blast the entire
series has seen Frieza extending one
hand to deflect the blast is smothered
in the white force of the kamehameha as
it erupts in a massive explosion
covering the sky as Goku looks on
exhausted the smoke clears revealing a
living will be it slightly bruised
the final panel of this chapter is
colored black
Goku now having gotten the confirmation
that Frieza wasn't bluffing all right
next up the original Japanese broadcast
original release may 15th 1991 airing
only about 12 weeks after the mangas
release of that very chapter titled
showdown the embodiment of flame in a
twenty times kaio-ken kamehameha Toei
animation broadcast - the very first
animated version of the scene everyone
in Japan and many around the world would
see so let's talk about it the first
thing I noticed with this version of the
scene was what they added to enrich what
was to come
for instance as freeze it was decimating
Goku the animators went above and beyond
the call of duty in making this beatdown
at the hands of Frieza as visceral as
possible you can feel every last blow
even this creepy but admittedly
effective angle what's more is once the
dialogue between King Kai and tension
hun takes place and it's revealed that
Goku has in fact been used in the
kaio-ken the entire time the audience
has shown similar footage from before
only this time with the kaio-ken visible
to us it's extremely effective and surf
to surprise me on multiple viewings
however while visual changes like that
expand on the mangas material to enhance
it all their changes while made in the
same spirit fundamentally changed the
scene from Akira Toriyama the source
manga this change is present in all
subsequent iterations of this scene so
I'll leave it up to you to decide if
it's welcome or takes from the original
intent of the scene after being knocked
into a namekian lake Goku struggles to
reach the surface for air only to be met
by Frieza moments before his head
breaches the water Frieza using only his
foot forces the sand under water until
finally he loses consciousness
Goku at this time enters a dreamlike
state where he has visions of what is at
stake and what is on the line
there's imagery of his loved ones as
well as Frieza laughing psychotically
with that Goku XY's shoot open and a
massive surge of energy pushes Frieza
off of them and this is where things get
even further from the manga Goku says
for the future of Gohan chichi earth and
Planet Namek I absolutely must not lose
this is distinctly different from Akira
Toriyama's original vision where go ku
didn't claim to be doing this for anyone
in particular but instead focus on the
GEMA sea of freezes claimed to be using
only 50% office full power trying to
weigh up his options in a strategic
manner once these lines are honored
however this scene returns pretty
faithfully to what the manga portrayed
albeit with a few angles altered for the
sake of animation flow everything looks
spectacular animated by a young
tadayoshi of omoro who would later
become the series character designer and
eventually the animation director for
Dragon Ball super this scene has a lot
of weight and impact to it complemented
as I said with the extreme angles and
some wonderful use of colors and effects
work Goku in this version is voiced by
none other than Masako Nozawa who in
this scene delivers one of my favorite
performances from her the delivery is
very convincing and matches the tension
the scene is trying to convey perfectly
notice the stress but measured delivery
[Music]
and finally the music throughout this
iteration of the show was produced by
the immensely talented schinsky Kikuchi
patents of this version enjoy his
uplifting melodies as well as his iconic
battle scores noteworthy as well
regarding the sound design of this
particular section there are moments
where they decided the scene will be
better served with no music and chose
their moments accordingly
next up the early Funimation English dub
original release October 12th 1999 over
eight years after the original air date
in Japan folks in the West finally got
an English dub of this seat however
there are a few noteworthy changes to
both the script and musical score as I'm
sure you are all aware titled embodiment
of fire this interpretation of events is
pretty much one to one with the original
Japanese version visually so let's begin
by discussing the dialogue differences
ranging from minor alterations like
referring to the kaio-ken technique as
the Kaioken to changing the thought
process of Goku entirely from what the
manga had written him as moments before
Goku is cast into the lake by Frieza
he says you might be stronger a hundred
times stronger than me Frieza and you
may have me down but I am not about to
give up now and I will do whatever it
takes even if it destroys me to finish
you off once and for all to give you
what you deserve this is a particularly
interesting choice of dialogue for one
of two reasons firstly it's a world away
from the strategic and overly
of mindset Goku was enduring this point
the manga where he was trying to gauge
whether or not Frieza was bluffing but
secondly because if this was something
he came to a realization about during
his existential nightmare underwater
that it might serve a somewhat similar
purpose to what the Japanese version
attempted to present however because
this is something he had said earlier in
the episode he really only is
reiterating what he said prior which can
serve its own strengths in a different
way I guess the English version of Goku
has an unfettered resolve in the face of
absolute destruction fighting for his
loved ones he is not going to compromise
his beliefs despite knowing he is
outmatched which I'm sure is something
that interests a lot of English speakers
who grew up with the show myself
included this gave me goosebumps when
they watch it as a kid it's an
inspirational outlook however it does
serve to further distance itself from
the original Japanese broadcast and even
further again from the original manga
source which might matter to you
depending on your own work the voice of
Goku in this scene is performed by a
young Shawn Chimel something that I
think is worth noting and interesting is
that this is near the very beginning of
his voice acting career having only
voiced Goku for about twenty or so
episodes prior to this very episode with
the role of Goku being his first outing
into the voice acting spear through
Shawn's own admission it wasn't a
profession he ever thought he would find
himself taking part in despite this
however he has got on the record in
saying that during these recording
sessions he made a concerted effort to
make each scream distinct from one
another showing not only an interest in
this area he suddenly found himself in
but also an enthusiasm to make the show
as good as he possibly could within what
he had control over lastly and quite
possibly the most obvious difference
between this version and others is the
inclusion
the Bruce Falconer score what might
amount to guitar solos and synth rock in
places on this particular outing in this
particular scene the score is much more
withdrawn and subdued achieving a very
distinct atmosphere compared to its
Japanese counterpart for example with
that done and out of the way it's time
to jump forward to Dragon Ball Z Kai
original release February 21st and
November 17th 2010 entitled Kaioken
times 20 at all or nothing' kamehameha
this episode was redubbed and released
on the 21st of February 2010 in Japan
and later that year on November 17th in
English the driving force behind the
Dragon Ball Kai Reed above the series
was to essentially have a recut
streamline version of the original run
of the Dragon Ball anime aiming to cut
out much more of the filler portions to
the story where possible however and
interestingly this particular scene and
collection of events associated hasn't
had anything of substance taken from its
initial release all of the footage for
the most part is present in this
iteration so let's focus on the dialogue
delivery of lines and music the
distinctions between the Japanese
dialogue and Kai and the original
broadcast while they exist our minor at
best and pretty much remain as faithful
as they ever have been with the same
voice actors demonstrating fantastic
performances however there are distinct
changes to the English read dubbing of
this scene having brought themselves
closer to the Japanese version
considerably Goku now comments on
whether or not Frieza is in fact serious
about his claim of using only 50% what
that said though it does strain again
towards the end of the kaio-ken
monologue where Goku says I just gotta
give it my all and show this guy you did
not mess with me and my friends again
this leads into the altruistic hero type
character which Akira Toriyama
intentionally steered away from during
his version of the scene with that said
though it is noticeable that 20 years of
playing Goku has given Shaun Chimel a
greater comfort in the role of Goku
delivering lions as naturally as you
would expect from a seasoned
professional of note also is the new
addition of Chris Aires taking the role
Frieza a person who liked the Japanese
voice actor of Frieza was almost born to
play this role this is no time to be
bemoaning your fate
after all fate is not the collision that
honor goes to your stubborn sense of
self-worth on the music front as we've
discussed in other videos the score for
this version was created by Kenji
Yamamoto and employs a more traditional
orchestral approach creating an
uplifting inspirational feeling as Goku
raises himself from the water
with all that said and done let's do
something a little different how about
we see how the climaxes of these scenes
compare that's right we're gonna compare
all of these Kamehameha beginning with
the earliest in the manga version and
finishing with the latest in the KY
versions and so to kick things off I'm
gonna lend my voice to the manga version
why sir yes sir
plain Kiku t-score truck MA 14 go oh
[Music]
sorry
blinky could discord truck MA 14 go so
as promised now that I have broken down
the original manga chapter from 1991 the
original Japanese broadcast from the
same year the early Funimation dub from
1999 and the Dragon Ball Kai version
from 2010 I would like to present you
with the opportunity to cast your vote
click here and let us know which
interpretation of events outline you
think presented at best don't forget to
leave a comment to let us know why you
chose what you chose and if you have any
suggestions for other scenes I should
compare leave them down below there in
the comment section too don't forget to
leave a like or dislike and I will see
you all in the next video thank you so
much for watching
you
[Music]